staff members of The New York Times
aren't doing that so I am definitely
going to come across stories and
information that I only I would know
about and their staff wouldn't know
about
here's something I think about why isn't
it that staff at the New York Times and
virtually any of the major media
institutes why aren't they thinking
about this topic more frequently
you'd have to ask them Kurt you know I
I don't know I mean except that you know
there's still a stigma and that stigma
is definitely still at play uh and the
New York Times covers so many topics
they would consider to be way more
important than this such as the war in
Ukraine you know all kinds of things
um they certainly have gone with the
Chinese balloon story but that's not
really the kind of story we're talking
about so
I I really can't answer that and it's
especially mystifying to me because the
stories that we've done so far have
gotten huge attention for the New York
Times
uh you know a huge number of people
viewing them the readers obviously loved
the stories and want more
but I can't speak for them I just know
that it they don't cover it on a regular
basis they will cover things like a
hearing that takes place in Washington
or when the report comes out you know
the odni report they have one of their
people cover that
um
so
yeah you I don't know uh people would
have to ask them people will have to
write to the editorial Department write
to them and say we want to see more
coverage of this
but I can't I can't speak for them but I
do know that that stigma is pretty
powerful at the New York Times maybe
more so there than a lot of other media
because they are considered the paper of
record and they're very cautious
and the Chinese balloon story you're
referring to what happened in Yukon yeah
I'm referring to everything starting
with the shooting down of the Chinese
balloon going forward from that I mean
that's been such a huge thing in the
media in the time says
doing a lot of coverage on that and
Helene Cooper's been part of that